[Music]
as the world's largest online retailer
it's no surprise that amazon has a
gigantic
warehouse it spans 2.3 million square
feet across four floors and the center
includes a highly automated
warehouse space for comparison the
empire state building in new york city
is 2.7 million square feet located in
phoenix arizona
this warehouse handles the bulkier items
that won't fit in a regular tote it
opened in 2011
and has over a thousand employees who
work 24 7 to ship various items
including furniture hockey sticks lawn
mowers and everything you can find on
the seemingly endless
amazon website with thousands of orders
rolling in every hour
amazon has no other option but to equip
their warehouses with highly efficient
people
and the very best in tech to aid them in
the process
today we take a look inside amazon's
largest warehouse
welcome back to our channel before we
begin make sure you hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell so you never
miss a video from us
the amazon warehouse or fulfillment
center as it's called in company jargon
is a uniquely 21st century creation in
the anchor of their physical operations
you can go on the app or the website and
buy things with a single click and it
all comes down to how efficiently the
people and the robots in this space
function
in order to get you your new iphone or
garden hose or board game
the building which is about the size of
36 football fields has
employees using technology to find the
items required to determine which size
of box to use for packaging
and where to ship it amazon likes to
keep its working process a secret from
the public giving
you almost the illusion of magic when
your box ships the same day you ordered
it but make no mistake
the work that goes into delivering that
product is long
and intricate its fulfillment machine is
finely tuned
not just to serve amazon itself but
anyone else who wants to sell their
products on the site that's right
more than two million third-party
vendors also use this space
amazon keeps its brand front and center
in these listings but these sellers are
still crucial to the company's
future they now supply about 40 of the
items sold on amazon annually
and last year third parties sold more
than a billion items worth
tens of billions of dollars so the
world's largest online retailer not only
lets other sellers list their items on
its website but lets them outsource
shipping as well the warehouse contains
two fulfillment operations working as
mirror images of each other
this helps the center scale up or down
depending on the volume of orders
the central mezzanine provides panoramic
views of both sides of the warehouse
and an impossible to trace web of
conveyor belts and rollers
move around items and yellow bins from
one point to another
filled with goods destined for either
the warehouse shelves or for customers
the inventory here is made up of
merchandise small enough to be stored on
shelves about the size of those at a
typical library which is exactly what
this space is called
each shelf is divided into cubbies and
each cubby has a barcode and an
alphanumeric id
interestingly these barcodes don't
signify anything about the type of
product in the cubby
everything is just stored wherever it
fits and identical copies are stowed in
spots throughout the warehouse
sounds random and inconvenient we get it
after all when you're in a supermarket
you find all the toothpastes in one
aisle and there isn't a random cake mix
thrown in there you need order in a
warehouse
especially one of this size while it may
appear chaotic it's far
from it you've probably heard the rumor
that amazon warehouse workers
on average walk 12 miles a day within
the warehouse to fetch and drop things
around
well that's no longer true because
identical products can be found all
over the warehouse a worker has to
travel less to find the product you
ordered
randomness also helps with managing the
wide range of items amazon offers
because it helps save space if you kept
a dedicated section for toothpastes in
the warehouse and it wasn't being used
because you haven't received a shipment
yet that usable space
is just lying empty it's more efficient
to use any free space available
but then how do they keep track even if
the product is a bit of a walk away
these warehouses are patrolled by robots
that can pick up entire shelves
and bring them to the worker working at
a fixed station
all right let's go through this step by
step let's say you place an order for a
fog free shower mirror from the store
shavewell shavewell ships its mirrors to
amazon
where they are stored in various
locations around the warehouse
trucks will arrive with boxes of goods
that the workers open
scanned and put into yellow bins the
conveyors route the bins to different
parts
of the warehouse where other workers
will unload them scan them again
and then scan the cubby in which they're
storing the mirror
this way the computer knows where to
find the shave well mirror or anything
else the customers asked for
it's also worth mentioning that amazon
charges third-party sellers for shelf
space
down to one-tenth of an inch and they
also take a cut out of the order's ship
but in exchange
they also offer marketing and
distribution services
so you can focus on your business so
it's a fair deal
but back to your order for the mirror
your order is funneled from amazon's
website to the warehouse
to a handheld scanner carried by all the
workers in the library
the scanners direct the workers to the
nearest cubby where the ordered item is
stored
this item is then picked scanned and
placed into a yellow bin which is also
scanned
it travels on a conveyor system to one
of many pre-packaging stations
where workers sort items into small
slots on shelves with wheels
those shelves are then rolled into
packing stations where another worker
packages the orders into cardboard boxes
the size of the cardboard box that has
to be used for the item
is also determined by a computer once
packed the boxes all head down to
another belt to get labeled for the
mailing address
sealed and stamped they're now ready to
head down to the final shoots before
being loaded onto trucks for delivery
in a way the amazon fulfillment center
is like a giant robot
amazon is looking into incorporating
more robots into its warehouses
in 2012 they acquired the company that
makes the robots called kiba systems for
775 million dollars
since then it has deployed over 100 000
machines across
25 warehouses worldwide kiva's robots
have taken amazon's random organization
strategy
and made it even faster the
click-to-ship cycle which is the time it
takes to pick a product from the stacks
pack it and ship it was around to 75
minutes when workers handled the process
manually
but with the help of robots the same job
is done in 15 minutes
warehouses equipped with kiva robots can
also load 50 percent
more inventory than those without them
still human hands and brains are still
the best tools for most jobs in the
center
currently amazon has maximum advantage
over its major retail rivals
none of which were founded as tech
companies first at the same time
no other tech rival and yes were
including the likes of apple and
microsoft can come close to amazon's
physical logistical advantage in retail
unlike software fulfillment centers
aren't built overnight
this practice likely took years of work
and trial and error and competitors like
alibaba have little chance of entering
the u.s
market when they couldn't even hope to
replicate amazon's insane infrastructure
for now that superiority means amazon is
defining the 21st century consumer
experience
sellers will always flock to amazon to
distribute their goods
and the speed and convenience of amazon
will have buyers coming back for more
amazon's warehouses are designed to be
wish fulfillment machines
equipped to feed their consumers once
with speed and precision
at a scale that still hasn't found its
limit we keep asking for things
and amazon magically makes it all happen
as amazon continues to expand its
capacity
the physical reach it can offer its
sellers extends even more
the same way cloud services have become
the foundation for businesses going
online
amazon's fulfillment centers act as the
networked hubs of the consumer economy
which frees up businesses to focus on
manufacturing
rather than distributing whether you
want to learn from the retail giant
or apply its logistics system to your
own business there are plenty of lessons
to learn from their process
amazon has raised the standards for
management and how workers pick
pack and ship products it has even
invited other businesses like shavewell
an amazon seller success story to
piggyback on its proven methods
and grow their businesses as well so
what do you think
let us know in the comments below if you
enjoyed the video make sure you hit the
like button
and check out the simply tech channel
for more videos all about
tech thanks for watching and we'll see
you next time